this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace jack out there awesome all
in one platform through the link in the
description below more on them in just a
bit
in all the long centuries that england
has been a monarchy some really terrible
people have ended up wearing the crown
it makes sense any system as old as that
is bound to produce a few lemons
multiple kings have been deposed by
their subjects one charles the first was
so hated that he had his head chopped
off and the monarchy itself was
abolished for over a decade with so many
bad examples to choose from it's
difficult to settle on just who was
worst but serious consideration must be
given to the man that wore the crown of
england at the beginning of the 13th
century a man that presided over a large
and prosperous empire and promptly
ruined all of it in a truly spectacular
fashion king john was never supposed to
have been king at all and his
unsuitability for the position was
quickly made apparent by well everything
he did he had all the cruelty of his
predecessors but none of their skill on
the battlefield little of their cunning
and absolutely no inclination towards
leadership of his subjects he was the
worst of all things a character so
cartoonishly villainous that he ended up
serving a fictitious role as the natural
foil of that most celebrated of english
folk heroes robin hood he was so bad at
ruling england that eventually his
people rose up in revolt against him and
he died in the midst of a bloody civil
war that was entirely his own making
this is the true story of a man who
almost single-handedly destroyed an
entire kingdom a man with so few
redeeming qualities that even the
relatively scarce positive steps taken
during his reign were done in an attempt
to bring him to heal
[Music]
john was born on christmas eve 1166 at
the royal palace in oxford his father
king henry ii had ruled over england for
a decade at that time and was in the
process of building an empire that
included not only england but most of
wales and ireland and the entire western
half of france initially no one really
paid any attention to john since he had
three older brothers his chances of
inheriting the english crown or indeed
any significant land holdings were very
slim as a boy john was seen as king
henry's favorite child though even he
didn't think highly of his future
prospects he jokingly referred to his
son as john lachlan a bad thing to be
known by in a society where how much
land you control directly correlated to
how powerful and important you were the
problem it seemed was that henry had too
many sons the king had planned for his
empire to be split up when he died to be
divided by princes harry richard and
jeffrey this left nothing for jon giving
any land to him would involve taking it
away from one of his brothers something
none of them were willing to countenance
indeed the familial squabbles over the
vast empire led to a number of armed
conflicts between father and sons in the
last two decades of henry's reign it was
after one of these conflicts that john's
mother eleanor of aquitaine was
imprisoned by her husband where she
would remain until his death jon became
much more important following the sudden
deaths of first prince henry in 1183 and
then prince geoffrey in 1186 leaving
only john and henry's second son richard
who was now the heir to the throne henry
used john to try and control richard
seemingly threatening to make jon his
heir instead of richard in order to get
him to do what he wanted richard chafed
at this and finally snapped in 1189
allying himself with the king of france
philip ii against his father henry was
ill by then a bleeding ulcer was slowly
killing him and the broken old king was
forced to capitulate the final straw it
seemed was finding out that his favorite
son john had decided it was in his best
interest to side with his brother in the
conflict in the middle ages familial
loyalty counted for little when power
and wealth were on the line but even by
the standards of the day it was a
stunning betrayal though anyone that
knew john personally wouldn't have been
surprised extreme self-centeredness was
already a well-established personality
trait in the prince at the time
[Music]
henry died soon after making peace with
his son and richard was crowned in
september 1189. before he even became
king richard's dearest ambition was to
embark upon a crusade to the holy land
the egyptian sultan saladin had captured
jerusalem from the frankish crusader
states in 1187 and richard wanted to
reclaim it for christianity it was to be
a massive pan-european effort with
richard being joined by king philip of
france as well as the holy roman emperor
frederick barbarossa richard raised vast
sums of money through the sale of royal
lands and officers as well as taxes to
raise an army and equip it but equally
important was to make sure his kingdom
didn't fall into chaos while he was gone
richard set up a regency government to
run england while he was gone and named
his four-year-old nephew arthur of
brittany the son of his late brother
jeffrey as his heir if anything happened
to him it's notable here that richard
took pains to ensure his brother john
wasn't a part of the governance of the
kingdom it was obvious that he didn't
trust him not to try and seize the crown
for himself while he was gone instead
richard tried to buy john off by giving
him vast lands and extracting a promise
from him not to visit england for the
next three years richard left for the
third crusade and things went reasonably
well for him he never made it to
jerusalem but he captured the strategic
cities of jaffa and accra for the
crusade estates and also agreed to a
peace deal with saladin that allowed
christian pilgrims to visit the holy
sites in jerusalem unmolested at home
however things were falling apart
richard's regency government collapsed
into inviting between factions and john
inserted himself into the mess to try
and take power for himself exactly what
he promised his brother he wouldn't do
richard had made enemies from sicily to
cyprus during his crusade and alienated
his allies in france and the holy roman
empire which quickly came back to haunt
him philip returned home before ridge
and quickly became an implacable enemy
allying himself with john to sow chaos
in england richard hearing of the
disaster unfolding at home left the holy
land but was shipwrecked on the way he
tried to take a land route home through
germany but was recognized and captured
by the new holy roman emperor who
imprisoned him a massive ransom was
agreed to on the crippled richards
empire financially for years to come and
richard returned home john's civil war
collapsed once richard came back to
england and he was forced to grovel at
his brother's feet for forgiveness it
was obvious that richard held john in
contempt and didn't view him as a threat
to his power since he forgave his 27
year old brother's actions as those of
an ill-advised child john was stripped
of most of his lands and exiled to
normandy richard spent the remainder of
his reign campaigning in france fighting
to restore the lands lost to philip
while he was on crusade richard was
perhaps one of the best warrior kings
england had ever had he was a talented
general and a fierce warrior gaining the
epithet the lionheart for his
achievements on the battlefield but the
titular king of england spent very
little time on the island itself and
never got around to fulfilling his
kingly duty of producing an heir to his
throne when he died in battle in 1199
his vast domains were thrown into chaos
and speaking of domains perhaps you want
to own one the online variety that isn't
if you're looking to build a new website
there's no better place to start than
with our friends over at squarespace now
more than ever people are getting
creative with their time they're
reaching deep into their savings
accounts to start a new business or
launch a blog to share their opinions
with friends and neighbors the world is
yours and squarespace is the perfect web
tool to help you fashion it into
whatever you like it's the platform to
use when you're ready to get started on
our next web project that you've been
thinking about are you looking to get in
and out quick without thinking too much
about what your website should look like
well bam use one of their quick
beautiful templates to make a website
that's fresh and for you like it's right
out of the box or maybe you're more of a
hands-on person you've got lots of
opinions and ideas about what exactly
your site should look like well
squarespace gives you all of the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about once you're
done setting up your website tinkering
with the design if you're so inclined or
maybe just playing around with the
colors there are so many extra features
that squarespace provides that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
membrane areas analytics commercial
options 24 7 customer support everything
you could ever want in one place so when
you're ready to get started on the next
web project it's got to be with
squarespace go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch your site go to squarespace.com
forward slash biographics to save 10 of
your first purchase of a website or a
domain
and let's get back to king john
[Music]
richard's sudden death left two possible
heirs to the english throne along with
the vast territories in france that the
crown held john as richard's brother and
author of brittany richard's nephew
richard hadn't designated a successor
before he died and the law of the period
was confused and unclear making conflict
inevitable much of the english norman
ability supported john who was crowned
king westminster abbey while nobles from
brittany angel and maine supported
arthur so did king philip of france who
saw a weakened england as strengthening
his own position initially john saw
success in the war against philip and
arthur he was able to defend his
position in normandy from phillips
forces while scoring a surprise victory
over arthur's forces at the battle of
mirabeau on the 1st of august 1202
capturing arthur and almost all of the
rebel leadership but all that he had
gained he promptly squandered through
his own personal shortcomings government
in the middle ages revolved around the
king but no king could run his
government effectively without support
from the nobles and john seemed
incapable of getting along with his the
king routinely alienated angered and
ignored advice from the nobles no matter
how close they were to him or how
powerful they were added to this was
john's pension for cruelty that was
considered excessive even by the
standards at the time the nobles he
captured at mirabeau were imprisoned in
such deplorable conditions that many of
them died offending and angering their
surviving relatives then jon shocked all
of europe when in 1203 he murdered his
16 year old nephew arthur after a
drinking binge throwing the boy's body
in the river more and more french nobles
turned away from jon and allied
themselves with philip who was on the
offensive in normandy by the end of 1204
the entire duchy which had belonged to
english monarchs since the days of
william the conqueror was now entirely
in phillips hands the french king
followed up on his success in normandy
by seizing anjo and poito as well
suddenly and spectacularly john had lost
almost all of his continental
possessions that his father and brother
had captured and offended for decades
[Music]
the dramatic loss of normandy would
dominate john's politics for the
remainder of his reign the king
desperately wanted to regain the lost
territory not only because he considered
it his birthright but also because the
inability to hold it was a personal
humiliation for him and the country he
led the problem was war in the middle
ages was expensive perhaps even more so
in relative terms than it is today since
standing armies didn't exist at the time
any proposed french invasion would
involve raising and equipping a large
body of troops as well as securing naval
vessels to transport them across the
english channel further complicating
matters was that in this era it was a
lot easier to defend territory than it
was to capture it the landscape was
dotted with castles that dominated the
surrounding area which could be
garrisoned and provisioned to withstand
months of siege an attacking force would
steadily be whittled down by the
elements by disease by battle wounds and
that was even before dealing with the
possibility of a relief army that could
march out to meet them in a pitched
battle all of this meant that once
normandy had fallen to king philip it
was going to be very very difficult to
get it back all of this might have been
overcome had england been led by a
charismatic leader or at least a
brilliant military commander henry ii
might have been able to do it or richard
the first but john wasn't his father or
his brother he was only a marginal
soldier at best competent but not
brilliant in the field as for charisma
he seemed to possess the exact opposite
of that people were repelled by him
especially the nobles few of england's
barons didn't gain anything by a
campaign in normandy hardly any of them
owned land in france in fact they were
increasingly jealous of the expatriate
french nobles who'd been displaced by
the war and had assumed positions of
power in john's court they felt that
since normandy had never been part of
england in the first place merely ruled
jointly by the same monarch that they
shouldn't have to spend their treasure
or their blood trying to get it back
especially not on behalf of a king they
were growing to despise john for his
part despised the noble's right back he
was exceptionally paranoid that any of
them might grow powerful enough to
challenge him he attempted to squeeze
them for the money he needed to conduct
campaigns in normandy through any means
he could come up with taxes levied on
noblemen by john included scottish a
cash payment made to avoid mandatory
military service inheritance taxes on
lands castles and noble titles import
and export levies on goods shipped
through english ports even forcing
widowed women to pay a tax to the crown
to avoid being forcibly remarried these
levies combined to put much of the
english nobility deeply in debt to the
crown which jon then used to control
them his favorites could have their
debts forgiven while those who
displeased him could be deprived of
their lands and their titles john's eye
for money didn't just fall on the nobles
either he also sold royal officers
including sheriffs to the highest bidder
he established import and export fees on
goods shipped through english ports
england's population of jews which were
permitted to live and do business in the
country only at the pleasure of the king
were heavily taxed a common practice
when monarchs found themselves short of
cash you'd think that with all of this
money flowing in king john would be able
to seize back his lost territory in
spite of the reluctance of his nobles to
follow him into war ah if only it was
that easy
in 1214 king john must have been feeling
pretty confident he was on campaign in
france at the head of an army that had
captured much of anjou and was still
making moves towards the french capital
paris after several failed attempts in
the previous 10 years it seemed that he
was on the verge of gaining back his
lost territory and then
disaster struck john's campaign hinged
on an alliance with the other major
player in european politics at the time
otto iv the holy roman emperor otto had
invaded france from the north while jon
was in the south planning to trap king
philip and his son louie in a pincer
movement philippinoto met each other at
the bridge bevin not far from the city
of lille on the modern day french
belgium border it was a fierce battle
for by heavily armored soldiers hacking
each other with swords maces and axes
typical for the high middle ages after
hours of fighting the critical moment
came when the french king and the german
emperor clashed in the center of the
field with their retinues with both men
nearly being killed and having horses
killed from underneath them after nearly
being captured by the french knights
otto was forced to flee the battlefield
his deputies the counts of flanders and
bologna were not so lucky and were taken
prisoner the imperial army had been
decisively defeated the loss at bouvoin
spelled the end of john's ambitions in
france left without allies he was forced
to sue for peace and once again
dejectedly returned to england
empty-handed by now things were really
reaching a breaking point the nobles of
england were on the precipice of
rebellion the discontent between john
and his subjects had been building for
years john's oppressive taxes were
making life difficult for more and more
people commoner and noble alike the fact
that all of this money was being
squandered on campaigns against the
french king that failed to accomplish
anything just made things worse there
were also serious questions being raised
about jon's behavior while it was
expected for wealthy men at the time to
keep mistresses it was considered
unacceptable for those mistresses to
include married noble women something
jon is known to have done several times
for that matter his wife isabella of all
joules might have been as young as nine
years old when she was married to the
king in 1199 and had already been
betrothed to another nobleman hugh of
lucinor neither of which apparently
bothered john that much he treated most
of his nobles with outright contempt
preferring the company of his toadies
the new man that he entrusted to help
him run the government instead of the
land in ability and in a move that had
serious political and social
consequences he had embarked on a
dispute with pope innocent iii that had
ended with his excommunication in 1209.
the pope also put the entirety of
england under papal interdict which
forbade the saying of mass inside any
church in the country at a time when
almost all of society revolved around
the church this was a serious blow the
two had reconciled in 1213 but the
experience still haunted the pious
kingdom wide and served to turn the
majority of england's clergy against the
king with so many enemies and so few
friends rebellion was probably
inevitable it finally flared up in the
aftermath of john's failed campaign in
france in 1214. a great coalition of
barons from the north of england banded
together in april 1215 in the city of
northampton and at the head of a large
body of men marched south capturing the
city of london john's position was
clearly untenable and in a last-ditch
effort to save his crown he sued for
peace
[Music]
the king met with his rebellious barons
on the 15th of june 1215 ronnie meet 20
miles west to london attempting to
mediate between the two was steven
langton the archbishop of canterbury the
negotiations went beyond the individual
demands of the nobles and raised
questions about the way kingdoms were
governed up to now no real checks on the
absolute power of kings to do whatever
they wanted existed either in england or
most anywhere in europe while english
kings swore an oath at their coronation
to rule in accordance with the laws and
customs that already existed in the
kingdom there was no legal recourse if a
king simply chose not to do so it was a
fatal flaw when a bad king like king
john came along put the entire system at
risk of collapse in an attempt to
rectify this what the nobles wanted was
a guarantee of their rights and
liberties under the law they wanted the
rights of the church to be respected by
the king protection from illegal
imprisonment and a fair justice system
that they could appeal to what they
especially wanted was the establishments
of limits on the king's ability to tax
his subjects without their consent the
two sides agreed to the great charter or
magna carta in latin on the 19th of june
the charter called for the creation of a
body of 25 nobles who were empowered to
coerce jon into complying with the terms
of the charter they would ensure that
the king ruled not according to his own
personal whims but according to the law
of the land most historians consider the
creation of this legislative body to be
the first english parliament neither
side really believed that the peace
agreement would hold for long this was
proved out when it defined john appealed
to his one-time adversary pope innocent
for help as part of john's peace
agreement with the pope he agreed to
make england a papal vassal state and
innocent believed that the magna carta
curtailed his own rights as a feudal
lord so he declared the charter to be
null and void it became clear to the
barons that if they wanted their rights
guaranteed by law they'd first have to
earn them on the battlefield
[Music]
the entire kingdom descended into civil
war in 1215. hard-pressed by john the
rebel barons turned to france for help
king philip proved reluctant intervene
in the chaos but his son prince louis
did not he invaded england at the head
of a french army of knights and
mercenaries and joined with the rebels
at london where they proclaimed him king
the barons had decided that they would
rather be ruled by a foreign king than
by john any longer despite being
excommunicated by the pope louis pressed
the war against john to a fever pitch
plunging the entire kingdom into anarchy
and violence king john seemed to be at
war with everyone his barons the french
the scottish who took advantage of the
chaos to invade northern england still
john had plenty of money saved from his
various taxation schemes enough to pay
for a sizeable royal army john would
attempt to fight all of his enemies at
once rather than compromise he was
defiant to the last but in the midst of
this even his body betrayed him in
september 1216 while long campaign john
contracted dysentery known at the time
as the bloody flux the same disease that
killed john's brother henry in 1183 and
john grew gravely ill as well likely
dehydrated due to severe diarrhea in
october the king was no longer able to
travel he was at newark castle in
nottinghamshire on the 19th of october
1216 when he died at age 49. one wonders
how he might have felt as he laid dying
his once prosperous kingdom brought to
ruin his continental empire lost and
england overrun with foreign troops but
really he had no one to blame but
himself his selfishness his paranoia and
his tyranny had brought all of this
misfortune upon him it would be left to
his successors to attempt to clean up
his mess
john's death proved a turning point in
the war with prince louis most of the
rebel barons switched allegiances from
louis to john's nine-year-old son who
was crowned king henry iii louis
suffered a string of defeats over the
next year that compelled him to return
to france and give up his claim to the
english throne henry would spend decades
attempting to recapture the lost
territories in normandy with no more
success than his father had the loss of
normandy marked a turning point in
european history the beginning of the
historic rivalry between england and
france that would reach its heights
during the hundred years war from now on
kings of england would rule from england
instead of from france and over the
course of the next century english would
supplant french as the language spoken
at the english court but it would be the
magna carta that would prove to be the
lasting legacy of john's reign the
failed peace treaty was revived by
henry's regency government as a
framework for governing england the
charter would be reissued several times
during henry's long reign and his
successors would either rule according
to its precepts or face resistance from
the nobles in particular from now on
whenever king wanted to levy attacks
usually to fund a war he needed to ask
parliament for it thus giving the nobles
and later the commons a stake in running
the kingdom no one realized it at the
time but the great charter would prove
to be the foundational document for
almost every democratic constitution the
world over not that john should receive
any credit for this of course the only
reason the magna carta was conceived in
the first place was because john was
such a bad king that the nobles wanted
to prevent someone as bad as him from
running wild throughout england ever
again perhaps the greatest testament to
how terrible john's reign really was is
demonstrated by the royal family
themselves over the course of the
centuries there have been eight kings
named henry six georges eight edwards
even two elizabeths but there has never
been another king named john in england
great britain or the united kingdom and
who can blame them after all who on
earth would want to be known
as king john ii
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do smash
that like button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always
thank you for watching